[Musica]
nell'era dell'attenzione dove la moneta
più costosa di tutte è il tempo voi
avete deciso di spenderlo qui ci sono
studi brand aziende che farebbero di
tutto per ottenere questa cosa da voi in
un periodo dove si tenta di comunicare
con tutti i mezzi possibili
l'attenzione è definita come il primo
stadio senza il quale la comunicazione
non è possibile
e c'è chi dice che chi controlla
l'attenzione controlli l'economia nelle
nostre giornate
viviamo sotto il fil rouge della
produttività e molti di noi hanno la
sensazione che si stia perdendo la
direzione persone vuole andare le
persone stanno cercando di tornare ad
emozionarsi a porsi domande di esplorare
se stessi e il mondo e lo siete non
siete una prova anche voi qui alte da
oggi come è una prova tutto il movimento
terra qui dentro noi ci dimentichiamo
del mondo là fuori e ci avventuriamo in
uno scambio di idee che ci si muove
qualcosa dentro ci emozioniamo emozione
dal latino ex muovere smuovere fuori il
mio lavoro e quello del mio team è
quello di realizzare installazioni
audiovisive immersive e sensoriali
lo facciamo per creare un momento
emozionale nelle persone nei più
svariati ambiti e gli eventi musei
retail wellness sinceramente per me è
irrilevante quali sia settori che mi
chiamo a lavorare
il punto è che ogni volta un occasione
per tentare di emozionare qualcuno in
questi dieci anni abbiamo utilizzato
qualunque tipo di tecnologia idee
creative e nel tempo è nato in me la
voglia di volere saperne di più anche
perché è vero che se voglio emozionare
le persone in qualche modo devo capire
come siamo fatti qui dentro è così
iniziato un percorso
che alimenta oggi anche il mio canale
youtube è un percorso dove ho iniziato a
pormi domande e troppe forse a
disperdersi per poi ritrovarmi con una
maggiore consapevolezza rispetto al
direzionare i progetti che realizziamo
ha dovuto imparare i concetti fuori
dalla mia portata relativi al mondo
delle neuroscienze tra chimica concetti
filosofici sono argomenti completamente
fuori da quello che al mio settore
però è anche vero che viviamo in una
società iperspecializzata c'è una laurea
e un approccio per tutto e forse
arrivato il momento per alcune cose di
unire i punti e anche nel mio caso non
posso pensare di emozionare le persone
solamente con le tecniche dello
storytelling quando a disposizione linee
guida neuro scientifiche e senso
dell'estetica la chimica e così via sono
tutti ingredienti per fare un bel piatto
è bello prendere un po da ognuno
bilanciarli però sapere anche bene dove
si vuole andare
quello che voglio fare oggi con voi e
provare a condividere alcuni di questi
ingredienti
immaginatevi come fare un manuale per
poter condizionare stimolare gli stati
mentali delle persone una sorta di nuova
consapevolezza emozionale
ma partiamo dall'inizio questa mattina
mi sono svegliato mi sono alzato sotto
il suono della moto attore del caffè per
poi muovermi a pensare alla giornata
sotto i fumi della rossa e poi
accelerare sempre più perché troppo suo
pensiero e dario ritardo per tutto per
poi trovarmi qui di fronte a tutti voi a
parlare di emozione proprio in un
momento in cui ne sto vivendo una che
abbastanza intensa
in questi momenti fuori dalla zona di
confort che si sviluppa il cortisolo
l'ormone dello stress ma anche l'ormone
dell'attenzione una rottura crea
scompenso disequilibrio il mio disagio
diventa il vostro lo si può fare come
racconto o anche a livello di percezione
visiva la mancanza di riferimenti visivi
costringe il vostro cervello di
utilizzare maggiormente tutti gli altri
sensi e da oltre duemila anni dai tempi
di aristotele che è tra i primi a
parlarne che si utilizza il
disequilibrio per catturare l'attenzione
ho appena iniziato a raccontarvi una
storia è già qualcosa di chimico sta
accadendo nella sala fate sviluppando
dopamina il solo fatto di raccontare una
storia di iniziare a raccontare una
storia ti porta a sviluppare cordoba
mina la dopamina e responsabile della
sensazione del piacere è la stessa che
vi porta a passare l'episodio successivo
su netflix nonostante dovessi andare a
letto cinque episodi fa è la stessa
dello shopping compulsivo a dopamina
chiama dopamina e ne volete sempre di
più soffice mente fa parte di quello che
si chiama reward system situato nel
sistema limbico nella parte più antica
del nostro cervello ha iniziato a
parlarvi della mattinata del odore del
caffè rumore della moka quella
sensazione di ovattamento mattutino fumi
della doccia la lingua dei sensi ci
aiuta a trovare un terreno comune per
entrare in sync fra di noi e quando
andiamo in sync sviluppiamo sito cina ma
sito cina è una delle sostanze più
potenti non solo nello storytelling e
quella che vi costringe a sviluppare il
vostro cane o gatto quando vi guarda con
gli occhioni con la stessa di quando vi
innamorate la sito cina è quella che
crea legame per questo nel momento in
cui si crea uno scompenso lo fate vostro
lo vivete in prima persona e non c'è
storia più importante della vostra
ci tenete quello che non tutti sanno è
che grazie a yuri hassan e il suo team
oggi sappiamo che qualcosa di
particolare sta accadendo in questa sala
i vostri cervelli e le stesse aree dei
vostri cervelli in questo momento sono
attive e producono delle onde celebrali
estremamente combacianti tra loro e con
le mie la si potrebbe chiamare telepatia
e invece si chiama brain coupling un
fenomeno molto studiato nel mondo delle
neuroscienze in qualche modo i nostri
cervelli sono in sync e operano allo
stesso modo la cosa ancora più
particolare è che se parlate di questo
talk qualcuno fra un'ora un giorno o fra
un mese il loro cervello si attiverà
allo stesso modo del nostro in questo
momento se condividete la stessa lingua
c'è solo una cosa strana che si è
scoperta a cadere ad un'audience che non
accade uno speaker nonostante in questo
istante siamo in sync siamo in sincronia
c'è una parte del vostro cervello in più
ad essere attiva una parte molto preciso
relativa all anticipazione in questo
momento sta tentando di anticipare tutto
quello che sto dicendo e lo fate di
continuo cervello è una macchina
predittiva è costruita per calcolare
anticipando ogni possibile scenario e
per economia cognitiva sviluppa un
possibile esito che sia anche quello che
gli fa sprecare meno risorse possibili
per cui molto veloce nel fallo ma non è
sempre curato emozioni esistono proprio
per questo motivo calcolare e
razionalizzare un processo dispendioso
per il nostro cervello che da solo
consuma il 25 per cento delle nostre
risorse pur pesando solo 2 per cento del
nostro corpo emozioni sono il motivo per
cui esistiamo ancora sono una necessità
primordiale ci permettono di velocizzare
qualunque processo decisionale perchè
dirette ho agito d'istinto
e stata una sensazione di pancia sono
scappato il nostro modo di percepire
reagire a tutto quello che sta per
accadere e sono potenti sono talmente
potenti da arrivare a condizionare fino
al 70 per cento delle nostre azioni a
livello subconscio
sì anche quando fate shopping
persino i profumi gli aromi hanno un
impatto sulle nostre emozioni e
sensazioni ho sentite questo momento
questo è il momento del succo del
discorso siamo passati da una situazione
di suspance e ora siamo in una sorta una
sorta di di flop flop quel momento di
massima concentrazione dove tempo e
spazio si aggirano sembrano rimanere
sospesi e flow è conosciuto da sempre
nella società nella cultura orientale ed
è stato portato alla luce dallo
psicologo cx mia e scientificamente
abbiamo prodotto indoor fina nei momenti
di flussi tra endorfina questi momenti
ci piacciono queste sorta di montagne
russe emozionali endorfina e benessere
puro è la stessa che sviluppiamo con il
sesso
non a caso la troviamo in tutti i
momenti di flo questi momenti di vorrei
essere qui non sto pensando null'altro
se non a questo momento preciso che
alcuni chiamano felicità altri massimo
momento di produttività la cosa
estremamente appagante per me
e quanto in un momento come questo dove
ci stiamo condizionando vicenda nel
fisico a livello chimico e mentale non
sia costruita solo da me ma da entrambe
le parti
in questo momento sia il relatore che
audience hanno un ruolo attivo e
chiamata the beholder share da parte
dell'osservatore è una teoria nata a
fine ottocento e che trova una conferma
a nero scientifica ad oggi spiega che il
nostro modo di apprezzare le cose e di
emozionarci e direttamente relazionato a
quanto siamo coinvolti nel risolverli a
livello cerebrale e non si riferisce
solo do racconto di fatto una teoria che
nasce con le arti visive un quadro
troppo realistico mi stimola poco non
c'è nulla da risolvere per cui devo solo
leggerlo al contrario
un'opera troppo astratta non permette al
mio cervello di trovare un pattern per
cui sviluppare un concetto siamo pagati
quando ci viene permesso di completare
l'opera
un racconto una situazione come questo
quadro di william torna la tempesta di
neve nel 1842 come terna molti artisti
hanno sfruttato questa teoria per creare
un bilanciamento per creare un vuoto per
permettere all'osservatore di poter
completare l'opera con il pennello più
importante di tutti è più potente quello
dell'immaginazione
ogni opera è comunicazione oltre
all'importanza di chi la esprime
salve che un osservatore la lega con i
propri occhi che la faccia propria
perché sia completa e per via delle
nostre esperienze personali di vita
vissuta ogni volta quest'opera sarà
nuova e diversa per ognuno di noi per
cui unica come persona abbiamo il potere
immenso di creare mondi lo facciamo con
il racconto con le parole
con il pennello della musica lo facciamo
sognando ogni mondo è un'esperienza e
ogni esperienza diventa parte integrante
di ciò che siamo
il punto è che siamo esseri umani ea
volte ce ne dimentichiamo
portiamo avanti tecnologie innovazione
ci proiettiamo nel futuro è l'unica cosa
che lasciamo per strada e la nostra
consapevolezza del sé e più grande
universo da esplorare e a portata di
mano e ognuno di noi ne ha uno è il
nostro corpo sono nostro corpo e mente
legate indissolubilmente siamo sistema
fatto di percezioni fisiche chimiche di
emozioni la scienza ci aiuta ma siamo
perfettamente in grado di viverle per
cui non aspettiamo ogni volta che ci sia
qualcuno a spiegarci come siamo fatti
scopriamo lo vivendo nuove esperienze ed
esplorando c vicenda perché siamo fatti
di esperienze
grazie
[Applauso]